اليوم هل يتجه الاتحاد الاوروبي نحو تصنيف
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه كمنظمه ارهابيه سعيد
ان يكون معي في الاستديو الزميل في فرنسا
24 وسيم نصر هذا توجه قائم هناك عدد من
النواب
يقومون بالخطوات الضروريه لتصنيف مجموعه
فاجنر كمنظمه ارهابيه هو عدد قليل يجب ان
نقول ان عدد قليل من النواب حتى الساعه
ونحن نتكلم اربعه
فرنسيون
وسعي وقد تمكن من التواصل مع احدى انبات
الذي امضت على هذا الامر وقالت لي ان هذا
يعتبر سياسي من قبل همم موجوده
ولكن يجب رفع الامر الان الى السلطات في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وان توافق السلطات على
ذلك التصنيف وان ذلك ياتي في السياق
التصنيف روسيا كدوله داعمه للارهاب يعني
هو امر يعني ليس ليس ليس بالسهل وربما قد
يتوقف عند هل يكون الامر اسهل عندما يكون
البلد الذي يدعم هذه المجموعه هو في حد
ذاته تحت عقوبه صعب جدا لانه قال لي هي
قالت لي انه تم تصنيف روسيا كبل داعم
الارهاب كيف يمكن الحوار معه بعد ذلك
النجم اخذ ذلك بعين الاعتبار ان ذلك موقف
سياسي هي قالت انه يمكن ان همم يعتمدوا
على الاتحاد الاوروبي بدل ان يمر بمجلس
الامن لكنها مدركه ان الخطوات صعبه وان
ذلك اكثر منه موقف سياسي ربما لن ياتي
بعده همم ما يتبع عمليا وحسيا لكن هدف
الهدف من ذلك هو ربما ايقاف الدعم المالي
عن فاجنر ومنع عدد من الدول من التعامل مع
غيرنا لكن كما انت تعلم يعني التصنيف
الارهابي همم يختلف من دوله الى اخرى تصنف
اعدائها سياسيين بالارهابيين هو حتى كيف
تصنف الارهاب او تصنيفه يختلف من دوله الى
اخرى هو كالكبابه ههه يتغير تصنيفه من
دوله الى اخرى ولما المتحده حتى على تصيف
ما هو ارهاب اه من خلال ما نحن نعمل عليه
شخصيا مصنف الارهاب وهذا ليس تصنيف دولي
عندما استهداف المدايين بطريقه بطريقه
خاصه
ومستهدفه لانهم مدانيين ل همم
لدفع الدوله المسؤوله عنهم الى موقف سياسي
يوافق ما من هو قام بذلك العمل اه وان
اردنا توسيع البكار اكثر من ذلك يصبح
التوصيف مطاطي جدا واكثر منه مواقف سياسيه
من ما هو لديه يعني تداعيات فعليه على ارض
الواقع الغريب في الامر ولا مجموعه فاجر
الان تقوم حتى في عمليه اشهار من خلال
القنوات التلفزيونيه والسماء حتى وسائل
الاعلام بزياره الموقع الرئيسي في روسيا
لهذه المجموعه يعني نعم هو تم استحداث
المبنى في همم في سامبل
مجددا لم يكن لديهم مبنى علما انه حتى في
روسيا همم
المؤسسات الامنيه ولا المرتزقه هي
المرتزقه ليست مسموح بها امامك من
الولايات المتحده همم مثلا قانونا ها
قانونا وبالطبع هم
نعم لك بلاك ووتر مثلا بالطبع اصعب لكن
همم اليوم اصبحوا يجب ان ان نتخيل انر هي
ربما همم راس
السهم لما ياتي قبلها وما سياتي من بعدها
هنالك السعي كبير لبيروجيين نفسه هو من
مؤسسي همم على همم
المجال الاعلامي في ضخ في ضخ ال- ال- همم
السرديه الروسيه انجازات تعبير ان كان في
افريقيا او في غرب ميلاد وتاتي فادنر كاخر
نقطه لتثبيت لتثبيت ذلك علما ان ذلك
هم يحاربون للكسب المالي وهذا ما رايناه
مثلا في عده في عده مناطق ووراء مثلا
هذا هذا في مالي ما نراه كل ما هو في
الاحمر يا المدن التي لديها مراكز ليفاجنر
ثابته ما نراه في اللون البرتقالي هي
مناطق عمل قوات فاغنر وما نراه كشرارات او
كائن فيجارات هي اخر المعارك الكبيره التي
اخترنا ان نضع على القاعه على القارطه لان
ما اكثرها المعارك ان كان ما بين الجهاديه
القاعده ودول الاسلاميه
او معارك قام بها الدوله الاسلاميه ضد
الجيش الملكي في تسيد او اخر معركه بين
الدول الاسلاميه والقاعده فين ذكي في 12
من الشاعر الحالي او هجوم بامكو في شهر
يوليو حيث هوجمت ثقلت كاتي وهي اكبر ثقنه
للجيش وموقع ثقل السلطه اليوم في معركه
وما اشير اليه الان هو انه منذ سنه انتشر
هذا لمكافحه تلك جماعه لكننا نرى انه
خرج تقريبا
خرج ذلك التقرير منذ ايام خلق اوروبا ولا
يمكن ان نراه ان كان ان كان لدينا وجود
التقرير وهو يوضح ما عملنا عليه هنا مرارا
تكرارا وتكلمنا به معك استاذ توفيق حول
وهو هذا هو هذا هو التقرير حول انه عندما
دخلنا على على خط المواجهه حصل هناك
[موسيقى]
هذا هذا لكنه فعليا ليس له ارتفع عدد
التجنيد لدى الجهاديين بسبب ما حصل من
تجاوزات له حقوق الانسان في وسط ماله خاصه
وما جائزه كمجزره مورا كمثره في كما زرت
همبري واليها والى ما هنالك من مجازر حصلت
على ارض الواقع ونرى وهنا نرى خارقه
المجازر وايضا مره جديده اخترنا كل قليله
من المجازر التي استهدفت خاصه الشعب
الفلاني في تلك المناطق واهممها مجزره
نورا
ودغوفري حيث تم توثيق ذلك من قبل الامم
المتحده من قبل مؤسسات حقوقيه من قبل
جمعيات محليه ووصل عدد القتلى في مرايا
الاكثر من 300 وحصلت المجزره خلال خمسه
ايام وهو ما امر كبير يعني خمسه ايام
وربما ان اردت بعد التفاصيل القوا القبض
الروس والماليين على احدى
زوجاته وهو ان الرقم الثاني في تنظيم
القاعده في في مالي
اتبعوا ما قالته لهم حيث اين يمكن ان يكون
موجود كوفه وتبعوا ما قالته حيث يصل لم
يجد كفوفه وتحصل المجال في موره مثلا خمسه
ايام من المجاز يعني ليست مجزره تحصل خلال
ساعه او ساعتين وينتهي الامر خمسه ايام كي
يعود الجهادين في اليوم التالي ويقوم
بدورهم بقتل من تعاون مع الجيش ومع الروس
اذن ليس من السيطر على الارض لهم ولدينا
فيديو يمكن ان ربما عن اخر معركه حصلت او
احدى اخ- اخر المعارك التي حصلت ما بين
القاعده والدوله الاسلاميه ونرى الفيديو
بعد المعركه وهي فيديو همم تحصلنا عليها
ولم يتم ولم يتم لم يتم اصدارها حيث نرى
الجهادي الدوله الاسلاميه ليست هذه
الفيديوهات
على دراجات على دراجات على دراجات ناريه
وليسوا يخافون من الطائرات المسيره وها هي
الفيديو نراها هنا اذا هي فيديو ليس خلال
المعركه بل بعد المعركه اخذوا الوقت
لتصوير اذا لان ليس هنا لغطاء جوي ليفاجنر
ومن هنا ال- ال- لب الموضوع ان مثلا في له
جماعه الدوله الاسلاميه
وحصل هجوم البارحه ليلا على مرات من جوه
يعني انت ترى سته كلمات من جويه يعني غدا
داخل المدينه نفسها اه وحصل هجوم على
الحين قد فروا مثل هجوم في منطقه الرشيد
يعني يعني ترى كيف توسع عملهم ونقطه مهمه
ثانيه انه جميع الفصائل الطاب من الفصائل
الطوارق التي حاولت صد الدوله الاسلاميه
هناك منذ مطلع العام الحالي فاشلت فمن دخل
على خط المواجهه دخلت القاعده على خط
المواجهه واصبحت هي من تقاتل الدوله
الاسلاميه في منطقه
في منطقه حيث لم يكن لها وجود قبل ذلك اذا
وقع فاجن على على الارض كان ايجابيا لمن
جهاديين
وحصل بطريقه جدا بدائيه لان المرتزقه
ليسوا لديهم سلاح جيد وهذا بقول من قاتل
بجانبهم من مالي وليس لديهم سيارات يتنقل
بها لانهم يتنقل بسيارات الجيش المالي ولم
يحصلوا على همم على دعم من الخارج اكثر من
شهرين هنالك في مالي لكن يكفي انهم وصلوا
الى مالي ووضعوا رجلهم في مالي واخرجوا
اجل الفرنسي اذا هذا هو الوقت السياسي
ولكن هي الامور لم تعد تقتصر على مالي
الان حتى بوركينا فاسو طبعا بوركينا فاسو
هو ما كنا نراه وصور بوركينا فاسو وحتى هو
وجمله قاعده على ثقنه للجيش اكبر ثقنا
للجيش في السوم في جيبه في ال 24 الشهر من
الشهر الفائت واخذنا بما فيها اه وذلك حصل
بعد اخر همم اخر عمليه اللي حصل على
الشرطه انقلاب لصالح كبتان همم وبعد ذلك
بيومين قام الجيش البوركيني بقصف الكره
الفلانيه على تسعه كيلومترات بعد من تلك
المدينه وهنالك من يقول ان هناك رجال
اعمال في بوركينا فاسو عملوا همم
قبل ان يطهى به كي يتقرب من الروس لكنهم
لم يفلحوا وللتذكير ايضا عندما اخذ الحكم
في مطلع العام الحالي اول من هنا اهو كان
بيروجين اي مؤسسنير واول زياره هو خارج
بوركينا فاسو كانت لي همم القاسمي غويتر
رئيس جمهوريه مالي اه ولكنه هنا طرب اكثر
من ذلك من الروس واليوم انك ساعه جديد مع
النقيب تراوري له تقريبا من الروس هنالك
سعي لذلك لكننا لن نعلم حتى الساعه ان كان
سيفتح ام لا هذه الصور
وانت حصلت عليها في البدايه
شكرا هي صور تم تصوير المفضل طائرات مسيره
لجيش فرنسي في مدينه محاوله تحميل
مقابر جماعيه
الجيش المالي بعد ايام بدانا نرى على مرات
لصلاه الاجتماعي هنالك من يريد ان يقول ان
هنالك
مجزره حصلت في ارسل الجيش فرنسي طائره
لمراقبه المدينه وحصلوا على تلك الصور حيث
نرى عسكريين ما جيش مالي ومن راجنر وهم
يضعون رمال على جثث وقمنا بتحقيق ووصلنا
الى ان تلك الجزء الذي نراها جثث لاشخاص
من ما من من انبوري تم قتلهم خلال ايام
قبل تلك العمليه وهي عمليه تضليل اعلامي
كان همم كهدفها الايقاع بجاج الفرنسي
واتهامه بتلك المجزر اذا نعود الى ما كنا
نقوله ان نفجر على الارض شيء وضخ الاعلان
حول شيء اخر وهي عمليه قائمه بحد ذاتها
ليس فقط فنجر المرتزق على الارض شكرا لك
متواصله على فرانس 24